Louise it's so lovely to get to sit down
and chat to you first things first
priorities I want to talk about strictly
tell me everything you can tell me about
strictly why now
are you excited it's really excited
really nervous more nervous than I
thought I'd ever be I've always watched
it I love the program and then I think
this is a little something for me a
really small snippet of going back 20
years ago to get back out there and I
know sing around and dance around well
the thing that would make me nervous
more than you know doing the Rumba in
the American Smooth to perfection it
would be how you fit it in all the
training it's going to be a really tough
regime how will you fit that in with
family life how are you and Jamie
managed that it's gonna be tough I've
got two boys the key thing that I'm
gonna always try hard to do is get home
as often as I can for dinner there will
be my moment with them make time with
them and just to try and catch up with
them and what were you cook for those
family meals oh I don't know Mike my old
classic is spaghetti bolognaise is it a
family meal I mean we're not very good
in my house at with various work
schedule things about sitting down
together do you actually get to sit
around a table I have to fight for the
time they have dinner together I think
for me it's fighting - the time I think
don't expect it too many nights a week
but just whenever I can and of course
getting them to all come off of there
okay oh the phones and tablets is chaos
I mean it's a fight I did hear some
statistic that a third of families
really struggle to keep tech out of the
family meal and keep it at you know away
from distraction I think now there's
something for everybody with technology
you can be too or you can be 90 and
there is something for somebody to do
we're both guilty of that as well I mean
I'm forever answering emails from work
from you know different countries at all
different times of the day you've got
your lifestyle blogs that you all sort
of like having to upload for them I'm
always checking things but put something
up and we're put a post up as I'm
constantly looking and I find that I'm
looking every 10 minutes Tech is it's
here to stay we need it and we
love it yeah and it's so important I
mean for me it's a big part of my career
and it's now plays quite a fundamental
part in in jobs and anything else that
you do it's without it our jobs would be
made harder without a shadow of a doubt
I think it's just about a time and a
place for me dinnertime is the one time
in the day that I'd prefer to not use
technology do you have any anti text
strategies for particularly around the
dinner table
well I was very fortunate to get my
hands on the DOE mio
pepper hack oh it's like an
old-fashioned pepper mill and there's a
button on top and you put it in the
middle of the table press the button and
it kills all the Wi-Fi around the table
so it's only then that there isn't any
Wi-Fi that you realize how much your
family have been dependent on it my most
important thing to teach my kids is to
be able to walk into a room and chat to
anybody and everybody yes absolutely
and be charming and to be humble and to
be confident and all of these things for
me they're the things that really get
you somewhere in life and that moment
and those life skills have been lost I
think that's really true I mean if you
think if they you know if they're not
practicing interacting at this level how
do you yeah put it on a bigger yeah
great I was present in a meeting or go
for a job interview and they can bury
their heads and actually before long you
realize they're not really chatting and
they're not learning the art of
conversation and so you've tried the
pepper hacker
yes been successful there any other
strategies groups of redressing the
balance of tech versus family we've got
a tick drawer so it dinnertime
everything goes in the tech drawer out
of sight out of mind and also the first
person that kind of succumbs and goes to
get it has to do the washing-up so that
is a another quite a fun way yeah I find
that that really works that's sort of
just that extending that interactivity
time not just that 15 minutes when
you're eating something that took two
hours to prepare get them to help you
know it really and they love it I think
yeah Louise thanks for chatting today
it's been really great to catch up been
great if in lovely senior and I've also
learned a lot and now I'm super excited
about Strictly I will vote for you
please do probably on my
had or rather did a time thank you